[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 loisirs chaque jeudi
l'essentiel des informations pour passer
un bon week-end dans les yvelines tout
de suite le sommaire de cette semaine du
dressage du cross et du saut d'obstacles
concours complet d'équitation investi
vite de loisirs de 50 ans milliers trois
jours de compétition qui débute le
vendredi 12 octobre une activité
conviviale qui s'adresse à tous les
publics la marche nordique fait
travailler jusqu'à 90% des muscles du
corps l'union athlétique de versailles
invite à la découvrir ce dimanche et
l'agenda complet de vos sorties au
programme du modélisme de la bande
dessinée et un retour dans le passé
la marche nordique est apparu en france
en 2005 une pratique développée à partir
de 2009 à la fédération française
d'athlétisme
ce dimanche se tient la première édition
de la nordique royal organisé par
l'union athlétique de versailles est
l'occasion d'aller supporter les
participants et pourquoi pas la tester
atv 78,6 y ait essayé miquel et demi
d'euros pour la technique
c'est un sport venu tout droit des pays
nordiques pas besoin de beaucoup de
matériel pour le pratiquer juste des
bâtons
la marche nordique allons la découvrir
bonjour armen bonjour mélanie quels sont
les bienfaits de ce sport et bien c'est
une marche dynamique que ces pratiques
dans la nature le plus souvent dans les
parcs et forêts environnantes
ici à versailles qui a besoin d'un grand
niveau s'est adapté à tout le monde
s'est adapté à tout le monde
faut être en forme et à quelques petites
contre indication si on a des problèmes
de tendinite mais sinon c'est ouvert à
tout le monde mais bon on peut le
découvrir
bien sûr j'imagine on voit les
participants on commence par un
échauffement servir
alors c'est parti
[Musique]
ça réchauffe et ça réveille
c'est très agréable parce qu'on sent que
tout se réchauffe petit à petit
j'attends de voir la marche
un échauffement nécessaire de tout le
corps la marche nordique sollicite
jusqu'à 90% de nos muscles
armen nous voilà bien les chauffer on va
partir sur la marche mais on a des
bâtons j'imagine qu'il manière spéciale
de s'en servir
oui tout à fait le bâton ce nous sert à
nous propulser donc pour ça c'est
important de lancer son bras vers
l'avant le braille plutôt tendu sa tâche
des anges et ensuite on va planter le
bâton derrière et on a toujours un bras
une jambe opposée et le bâton se plante
derrière l'a fait d'accord
sport très conviviale la marche nordique
se pratique idéalement en groupe grâce
au bâton en carbone un marcheur peut
atteindre 6 km heure très vite la marche
devient naturel alors si vous aussi vous
voulez essayer une séance d'initiation
est prévue le dimanche très attendu à
10h30 et ça commence dès l'âge de 16 ou
17 ans
puis de 200 cavaliers de six
nationalités différentes réunies à lille
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
du 11 au 13 octobre c'est le sky
eventing show et pour en parler avec
nous car ils piccinini mme bonsoir
bonsoir
alors vous êtes responsable du sky
équitation qui accueille la compétition
les cavaliers ont été accueillis
aujourd'hui tout va bien tout le monde
est là en train d'arriver là petit à
petit entre aujourd'hui et demain ils
s'installent tranquillement tout se
passe bien
alors comment le club en est venu à
accueillir et organiser une telle
compétition a passé un petit peu un
challenge pour nous on a déjà organisé
des compétitions de de niveau inférieur
donc clubs amateurs ou pros et là
c'était un petit peu notre défi no
challenge d'organiser cette compétition
de haut niveau
donc ça avance et tous un petit peu
fédérer autour de cet événement et voilà
ça s'est mis en place petit à petit puis
là où là on y est c'est georges et vous
qui vous êtes porté volontaire c'est la
fédération qui est bouleversant c'est
nous l'équipe d'une manière générale un
mouvement d'ensemble qui s'est portée
qui s'est porté candidat pour pour pour
organiser sa sky citation c'est un moyen
de faire découvrir ce qu à l'équitation
c'est est-ce que également moyens douala
de nous ouvrir un petit peu au public
l'île de loisirs sera ouvert du coup ce
week-end les barrières seront ouvertes
ça permet aux gens de venir découvrir
sky équitation aussi puisqu'on accueille
quand même nous des cavaliers c'est
notre métier on leur apprend à monter à
cheval dès l'âge de 2 ans donc ça permet
d'ouvrir de s'ouvrir un petit peu à
l'extérieur au public c'est un beau
spectacle
j'arrive vraiment tout le monde à venir
ce week-end ça va être du beau spectacle
ce week-end c'est un concours complet
donc si je ne fais pas d'erreur ces
trois épreuves ces trois disciplines
tout à fait donc on a d'abord une
discipline de dressage on a une
discipline de saut d'obstacles donc sur
un grand parcours d'obstacles et sur la
carrière et on a une discipline de cross
country donc qui va se courir sur les 6
hectares de cross vallonné que nous
avons que nous avons la chance d'avoir
la base kayak équitation
ça veut dire que les compétiteurs ont
les capacités d'être sur les trois
épreuves qui sont les pourtant très
différentes mais qui sont pourtant très
différents c'est ce qu'on appelle des
complétistes donc et les chevaux sont
pareils donc c'est des cavaliers des
chevaux qui sont performants et
entraîner sur ces trois disciplines
alors la particularité c'est qu'en plus
il ya des professionnels mais il ya
aussi des amateurs on aura donc tout
voilà vous avez vraiment de tous les
niveaux de l'amateur qui commence à se
mettre en concours complet aux propos de
la discipline dont c'est le métier
est ce que c'est un moment important
dans la saison d'un cavalier oui une
telle compétition et les concours
internationaux c des qualifications au
cir pour ses cavaliers pour pour faire
d'autres choses pour la préparation de
leurs chevaux donc c'est toujours des
échéances qui restent importantes en
fait parler les barrières sont ouvertes
c'est-à-dire en plus c'est gratuit
oui c'est ça les barrières vont être
ouverts donc les gens vont pouvoir venir
découvrir cette île de loisir découvrir
sky équitation tout le week end alors
découvrir mais ils vont pouvoir voir ils
vont pouvoir tester pouvoir voir déjà
effectivement tout tout ce concours ce
beau spectacle et nous on organise nos
baptêmes poneys également donc chez les
enfants qui sont là c'est l'occasion
s'ils mettent de commencer à mettre le
pied à l'étrier
est ce qu'il ya des inscriptions à
prévoir pour nous entendre c'est en
continu toute l'après midi de 14 heures
à 18 heures ils peuvent venir faire
leurs petits tours à poney ces portes
ouvertes ils viennent quand ils veulent
on disait tout à l'heure il ya trois
disciplines est ce que ça va se passer
en même temps ou est-ce que l'emploi du
temps et est cadré par rapport aux
disciplines alors on a un emploi du
temps qui est cadré par rapport aux
disciplines mais dans l'organisation et
par rapport au grand nombre de cavaliers
qu'on accueille il ya des disciplines
l'obstacle va se passer en même temps
que le cross pour certains cavaliers
voilà quand il y en aura sur le cso il y
en aura aussi sur le cross et
inversement choisi c'est l'occasion en
fait de tous de pouvoir pouvoir en
venant parce qu'il y aura des cavaliers
qui sont en train de dérouler leur
reprise de dressage et le saut
d'obstacles ça permet de tout voir du
coup donc c'est intéressant aussi
il y aura vraiment beaucoup d'activités
le ska d'autres échéances peut-être si
jamais on peut on rate ce rendez vous là
ce que alors allez on organise alors
international pas tout de suite là on se
lançait le premier je pense qu'on ne
refera par contre tout au long de
l'année
on organise quasiment deux fois par mois
hormis pendant l'hiver une fois par mois
on organise des compétitions les
dimanches à que ce soit de l'obstacle du
dressage du concours complet donc faut
pas hésiter
on a un autre sur notre site internet
tout est indiqué il faut pas hésiter à
nous appeler
si besoin merci karim continue
d'ailleurs le concours complet
international débute ce vendredi 11
octobre à lille de loisirs de 50 ans
divine et maintenant on parle de culture
[Musique]
au festival de bd de bus près de
cinquante auteurs sont attendus
et parmi eux des collégiens deux
établissements de plaisir et dangereuses
ont participé à un atelier encadré par
le dessinateur bucquoy marc védrines
c'est l'aboutissement de huit mois de
travail ces collégiens sont devenus le
temps d'une année scolaire scénariste et
dessinateur de bandes dessinées
j'ai déjà envie depuis longtemps de
faire un métier dans le dessin donc bah
ça a sorti plus fort un projet en route
ça lui permettait de plus participé et
puis tout le monde peut y participer ils
veulent pas connaître une réponse ou
vous proposer nos idées
mon bien et storyboards c'était sympa à
faire en classe avec une subvention
puisque et toutes les ssii qui
s'entrechoquaient c'était sympa du coup
de voir les plans ce défi au tableau un
travail réalisé en classe dans deux
établissements et binoy blaise pascal de
plaisir et georges pompidou à orgerus 97
élèves ont planché sur le thème
fantastique en cours de français et
d'arts plastiques se fait très vite
c'est que ça les a soudés
ç'a permis aux classes d'être vraiment
avoir une cohésion dynamique
intéressante
après il ya des élèves qui ont des
talents naturels pour le dessin qui se
sont évidemment très épanouie dans le
dans ce projet le coeur au contraire été
plus en difficulté mais qui n'ont pas
pour autant été laissé son bord du
chemin
le projet a été pensé par la ville de
buc est soutenu par le département des
yvelines
les quatre classes ont été encadrés par
un auteur reconnu marc védrines auteurs
d'islandia forces spéciales quand on met
pas du métier on réalise pas à quel
point
réaliser une bande dessinée ça demande
beaucoup de rigueur beaucoup de travail
et on recherche de documentation de
costumes il ya des histoires qui sont
membres qui se passe en 1870 il faut
faire des recherche de décors de
costumes tout ça comme leurs illustres
aînés ces apprentis bédéiste exposeront
voir dédicaceront leurs créations lors
du festival qui se tient les 12 et 13
octobre un lot de cinéma présent cette
semaine c gueye pineau du crêt du
grenier à sel de trappes qui donnent
rendez vous on les écoute
[Musique]
cette semaine au cinéma grenier à sel
nous vous proposons l'apocalypse n'a
dans une version directeur scott c'est à
dire que c'est une version qui a été
remasterisé le l'image et le son a été
remasterisé l'image et en ultra haute
définition 4k donc ça va on va bien en
profiter sur notre projecteurs sony 4k
et le son a été remisé en cinq points
nous nous retrouvons
ce sera donc le vendredi 11 octobre à
20h45 au cinéma le grenier à sel ce film
apocalypse now est un film c'est le film
incroyable de francis ford coppola qui
nous embarque dans la folie de la guerre
du vietnam
mais la folie s'est aussi emparé du film
le tournage s'est éternisé dans la dans
la jungle des philippines marlon brando
arrive sur le tournage il est obèse il
connaît pas son texte
l'acteur principal qui est martin sheen
il fait une crise cardiaque en plein
tournage et évidemment il ya plein
d'autres mésaventures sur la
post-production donc ce film qui sera le
vendredi 11 octobre à 20h45
il fait partie de programmation annuelle
de films de patrimoine le prochain
rendez-vous sera pour halloween avec
l'étrange noël de monsieur jack 2
novembre venez en famille et des visées
pour mettre de l'ambiance
[Musique]
avis aux passionnés et aux curieux les
trains voitures et avions de modélisme
reviennent les amis des flots et les
passionnés du train investissent à la
fin du manet ce week-end 1200 m² pour
aller à la rencontre des collectionneurs
et vous pourrez même tester certains
modèles sur un grand bassin un
simulateur de vol et un circuit de quoi
faire revivre votre un nombre d'enfants
on écoute les présidents organisateurs
chez surtout une grande une grande
exposition vraiment cheap et pour la
famille accessible aux enfants donc il y
aura plein d'animations et d'initiation
pour les enfants ils pourront faire
naviguer les bateaux faire rouler les
voitures s'essayer au pilotage d'avions
radiocommandés
en fait vous il faut pas oublier qu'on
crée des jouets on fabrique des jouets
pour les jeux un peu onéreux mais ce
sont des jouets quand même et beaucoup
de personnes qui viennent nous voir nous
disent mais c'est vrai quand j'étais un
gamin j'avais déjà un réseau de trains
miniatures ou des bateaux ont fait un
saut dans le passé avec notre nouveau
rendez vous depuis un mois rambouillet
vit au rythme des sixties des ventes aux
enchères une projection de film balade
en deux roues le lion's club de
rambouillet multiples les animations au
profit d'oeuvres caritatives écouter le
slogan c'est 60 jours d'animations sur
les années 60 pour les plus de 60 ans en
difficulté alors notamment les malades
d'alzheimer
vous savez que lyon ce club a lancé les
centres d'accueil de jour alzheimer
il nous en avons à rambouillet il y aura
ensuite les personnes qui ont des
problèmes de vue un bibliothèque sonore
la vue qui baisse après 60 ans
les handicaps physiques et mentaux c'est
la fin de ce cette ut loisirs merci de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve jeudi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]